pour vous parler de virginia benedicto
je vous dirais que de mots créativité et
bonne humeur
virginia benedicto est passé par mieux
de la pub et cela se voit né à madrid
l'artiste qui s'est installée olivet
depuis seulement un an adore les
matriochkas les couleurs vives et les
rudes la rondeur pour moi ça rime un peu
avec avec le la douceur c'est ce qui
rompt c'est plus et plus joyeux que
quelque chose qui est qui filiforme que
j'assimile plutôt à quelque chose de
froid
donc j'ai toujours j'ai toujours
travaillé dans la rondeur avant je
faisais des grosses femmes j'étais
tellement comparé à une équipe saint
phalle que voilà j'ai arrêté les mémés
grosses femmes mais elles sont priées
elle est quand même plus dodue qu'une
vraie poupée russe aussi c'est vrai
l'artiste travaille sur une résille
commandé un artisan local puis elle
prend son temps le très méticuleux les
entre l'action précis et des
compositions millimétré
chez elle pas de pessimisme affiché ses
créations font toujours une invitation à
la joie de vivre qu'est ce qui fait
justement que ça plaît ce que vous
faites
je pense qu'on est plus au temps où il
faut exprimer tout son mal-être dans sa
peinture vous savez les peintures un peu
torturé et tout je pense qu'on a quand
même passé le cap
aujourd'hui les gens ont besoin gaieté
ont besoin une zone couleurs ont besoin
de
puis s'intéresse comme beaucoup plus à
la déco quelques années et c'est vrai
que dans les intérieurs les mp dizaines
de choses coloré guerre et fort de cette
tendance déco ses créations dont aucune
difficulté a exposé plusieurs galeries
parisiennes et même poussé l'oise ont
déjà franchi le pas
et les rock animal et poète elle adore
barbara et patti smith elle est auteur
compositeur et actrice demi mondaine est
ce soir en concert à saint jean d'arvey
l on ne va pas s'ennuyer
voilà qui va ravir les préadolescentes
talent la jeune chanteuse et danseuse
encore israélienne est de passage à
orléans avec son infinie tour
avec son album triple platine 300 mille
exemplaires vendus elle est sans
conteste un vrai phénomène
m
ce sont des spécialistes du piano à
quatre mains et les interpréteront du
moussorsgki dans les tableaux d'une
exposition
l'âme slave a retrouvé ce soir avec le
but onuci chauvel et xavier verte
des gigolos contours indistincts qu'est
mobile ou comment se poser quelques
questions sur le contact le croisement
et la résonance
quatre artistes pour quatre pratiques en
emboîtement avoir au pays où le ciel est
toujours bleu
capturé le vrai le simplement beau ce
que l'on a oublié de regarder ou ce que
l'on ne regarde plus long et d'aumale
est une jeune passionnée de photo ces
clichés sont à voir aucun bilan
pas d'agenda la semaine prochaine pour
cause de vacances scolaires on se
retrouve donc début novembre à bail